l'année prochaine comme je vous l'ai dit
arrive à grands pas
[Applaudissements]
ça fait au moins 10 ans que je suis
passé un bureau
c'est un délire c'est un délire
vous avez vu que j'ai un téléphone rouge
peut m'appeler à tout moment à tout
moment j'ai fait une rigole à te dire je
vous raconte un truc
j'adore parce que moi
j'ai rigolé tout à l'heure parce que
tout à l'heure je suis allé au paddle et
en fait la dernière fois j'ai fait un
tournoi et il en fait ils font des
poules et il y a le meilleur premier
donc le premier qui passe et il y avait
dans une des poules il y avait six
poules le meilleur deuxième donc c'est
par rapport au score que tu as fait si
tu as perdu ou pas et il y a deux mecs
qui ont menti sur leur score donc si on
dit qu'ils avaient perdu difficilement
pour peut-être être meilleur deuxième
donc là donc là ils arrivent devant le
juge arbitre et des comment tu as perdu
il dit il avait perdu genre 60062 et ils
disent on a perdu
il lui donne un autre score donc il
grille qui a un problème
donc là c'est là que je rentre en scène
ah oui qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette histoire etc
médiateur donc là je me fais passer pour
le président de la Fédération Française
de paddle
et j'appelle les deux gars tout à
l'heure et je leur dis on détecte des
potes et je leur dis voilà c'est
possible d'une amende de 15000 euros
et les mecs je leur dis 2 ans de
l'interdiction de toucher une raquette
quelle qu'elle soit
les mecs en stress total on stresse
totale et je dois donc je l'aurais pas
dit que c'était pas vrai donc si il me
regarde
romain et Nicolas sachez que c'était
faux c'était une balle voilà donc
on a pleuré au téléphone
ils ont avoué ils ont dit voilà on les a
pris la main dans le sac donc je leur ai
dit attention attention c'est la
dernière fois non mais c'est alors moi
je vais vous dire il y a un truc où je
ne triche jamais
non alors non non alors franchement je
ne triche pas mais il peut m'arriver
d'essayer de tricher pour voir si les
gens suivent voilà bon
les séries donc comme je vous l'ai dit
là nouvelle saison arrive à grands pas
il va y avoir énormément de surprises
énormément de nouveautés allez-y
n'hésitez pas à passer hein c'est qui
qui est passé là c'est qui qui est passé
comme un fou là mais qu'est-ce qu'il a
allez quoi il y a une urgence c'est quoi
c'est LE SON
est-ce qu'on m'entend on m'entend et les
autres non
[Rires]
voilà
il est passé comme une balle qu'est-ce
qui se passe il a un problème ou quoi
les mecs on a volé un une pile ou quoi
n'hésitez pas à m'en parler donc les
chéris chaque jour avant cette nouvelle
année vous le savez chaque fin d'année
on fait bien entendu les entretiens
individuels
et chaque jour je recevrai de
chroniqueurs
qui me diront s'ils ont pensé de leur
année et quels sont peut-être leur vie
velléité pour l'année suivante on va
démarrer par deux chroniqueurs
aujourd'hui
Géraldine maillet et Benjamin Castaldi
bien sûr c'est deux salles de ambiances
deux années complètement différent
sachez que j'ai pris une personne en
haut
et une autre j'ai pris une tête de
classe et une queue de classe
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trois
avertissement exclusion encouragement et
si c'est les félicitations c'est
moi-même qui les donnerait les Féloche
et je donnerai pour cela un petit cadeau
une prime petit cadeau un mini
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial énorme
un mini surligneur voilà
usage unique bien entendu merci alors
nous sommes donc aujourd'hui je prends
l'agenda parce que j'en ai un ici tout
est prévu et avant de vous recevoir
lundi 8 mai c'est fait victoire 1945
s'est faite du travail c'est fait alors
je vous le dis on arrive à grands pas
vers le jeudi 18
jeudi de l'Ascension c'est donc dans une
semaine forcément
[Musique]
je pense que on verra pas ma gueule
donc là je vous dis un petit peu ce qui
reste quand même émission donc mardi on
est là mercredi on est là jeudi on est
là vendredi vendredi il faut que je
vérifie
chez vous et votre chambre
extraordinaire
lundi 15 je serai là
mardi 16 également mercredi 17 oui et
ensuite bien entendu ascension
donc on sera pas là ni pour la sainte
Yves ni pour la saint Bernardin
on reviendra lundi 22 pour la
Saint-Émile ah Saint-Émile tu me l'avais
toujours dans le mille on est là
lundi 22 mardi 23 sera là mercredi 24
aussi jeudi 25 au 6 et pourquoi vous ne
me voyez plus le vendredi sachez que
l'année prochaine bien entendu je
reprendrai les vendredis tout le temps
mais là aussi pour des raisons et je le
dis pécuniaire je vous jure je dis toute
la vérité vous pouvez vérifier sachez
que l'émission coûte moins cher avec
Castaldi qu'avec moi à la chaîne
forcément beaucoup moins cher
ça dit non la chaîne m'a demandé de
faire de doigts ça serait sympa en plus
et puis voilà donc voilà
donc vendredi le vendredi je ne sais pas
encore si je travaille ou pas j'attends
la chaîne c'est eux ils m'appellent ils
sont mon numéro hein ils ont mes
coordonnées au pire des quais viennent
me chercher moi je suis à deux pas
on prend
on sera pas là pour la sainte Augustin
c'est un samedi
ensuite tu arrives le dimanche de la
Pentecôte
j'ai l'impression que là le lundi 29 est
grisé et j'ai l'impression je crois
avoir compris
cet agenda
apparemment qu'on s'est grisé c'est
férié
donc lundi 29 non on me dit qu'a priori
on est là donc lundi 29 vous pouvez le
cocher on travaille lundi 29 et si les
dates
jamais la saint Ferdinand je serai là le
30 et ça sera l'anniversaire de ma sœur
de ma sœur que j'embrasse
mercredi 31 Visitation
le mercredi 31 apparemment c'est les
visitations apparemment on va visiter
les choses et on sera là
Saint-Justine non Justin j'adore voilà
Blandine on sera là et le premier on
sera là après pour les vendredis je vous
dis là j'attends truc et après ça sera
un déferlement puisqu'on sera toujours
là
[Applaudissements]